[Musique]
alors mon nom est john paulson
ouais je m'appelle rachel breton jacques
lessard mme josée couture ou
personnellement je me considère pas
comme nulle comme une personne âgée j'ai
71 ans mais encore hyper excitées 73 ans
j'aurai 80 elle fait doux aussi des oui
ces projets au plus fort de la pandémie
le gouvernement a voulu protéger les
aînés quand on regarde l'été c'est qu'on
a à québec au québec à ce jour 89 % des
décès sont des personnes de 70 ans et
plus certains c'est vrai sont fragiles
mais pas tous on me dit comment tu as
you know vieux de plus de 70 ans cherche
mon miroir de sa marche en pause pour
moi
que veut on n'est pas tous vieux de la
même façon il ya un accent très vivace
d'auxon annuel comme les plantes par les
temps qui courent on a tendance à mettre
tout le monde dans un même compagnie les
actifs les pactes sifflet perclus
malheureuse qui sont dans des maisons de
retraite dans les châssis sodi ceux qui
sont à la maison pour le gouvernement
tous les gens âgés de 70 ans et plus
sont plus à risque de souffrir de
complications graves s'ils contractent
l'aco vide
c'est une généralisation qui en a heurté
plusieurs et je pense que notre société
devrait prendre plus en compte la cette
réalité de gens qui sont encore dans la
force de l'âge
les mêmes qu'au delà de 70 ans qui sont
très actifs et guitare bdk font la
différence
ben moi je me lève que je voulais juste
la belle journée occupe le sais plus je
me dis c'est au legs liquide
alors voilà pour moi c'est toujours bon
un bonbon cercle d'amis qu'on n'a pas
vus depuis trois mois c'est sauf au
froid être contentes de se réveiller à
tous les matins moi je vois des gens qui
se laisse vieillir sans rire
agir comme si la vieillesse c'était week
c'est inéluctable mais ça n'est pas
inéluctablement plate et je n'accepterai
pas de vivre quelque chose de classe non
la crise a fait peur à beaucoup d'aînés
qui ne voit plus les ch et cd de la même
façon
ben ça nous fait réfléchir quand voudra
pas y aller je veux jamais y aller
or autant que possible je me voyais ça
me va pas aller dans place comme ça mais
de grâce si on peut rester aussi
longtemps que possible dans nos demeures
aussi longtemps qu'on en est capable
avec des services d'appoint ça va être
parfait ça va coûter moins cher à l'état
il savoir en nos sociétés globalement
plus grunge
pour plusieurs la crise qu'ont traversée
les aînés plus vulnérables a plutôt
affirmé leur volonté de vivre pleinement
malgré l'âge qui avance je vois le temps
passe et je vois les gens vieillir
autour de moi j'ai une marque à 97 ans
et demi je sais c'est quoi je sais ce
qui m'attend mais je veux pauvres ça se
passe d'une façon où je vais être obligé
de me retirer de la vie active
parce qu'on peut être actif à tout âge